on est passé par la concertation on est
passés par des petites actions
aujourd'hui on n'a pas d'autre choix que
d'être ici déterminée pour essayer de se
faire entendre et faire entendre des
messages
[Musique]
on considère que la politique agricole
commune qui est en pleine refondation
aujourd'hui correspond un plan social
qui met aujourd'hui depuis de longues
années à peu près quinze mille
agriculteurs chaque année et il les
emmène vers pôle emploi parce qu'ils
doivent quitter leur métier
d'agriculteur et la semaine dernière le
ministre a rendu des arbitrages qui
n'ont rien à voir avec toutes les
contributions qui ont pu être faites
[Musique]